can you tell us about the day Steven
that you were not accepted to film
school oh
that was a wonderful time
um yes I try to get into Film School in
Central Florida at the University of
Central Florida mostly due to the Blair
Witch Project the success of that coming
out of there that was a really
inspirational movie for me and there you
had to go through a two-year program to
be able to be accepted into the film
school and so I had a bunch of friends I
was in a film club I was doing a bunch
of shorts and things with them and then
we all submitted I was the weird genre
kid I was the one that wanted to make
horror movies and action movies and
comedy and everyone else was kind of the
artist filmmaker so all of my friends
ended up getting in but me uh because I
was the weirdo so it
you know that that was disappointing of
course because you spent two years
trying to to get into a program but
what I did was I ended up leaving school
at that point moved over to Valencia
College and finished up my a degree and
then spent the rest of my college fund
on my first feature
which is called the night owl and went
out with friends in the woods with a
camera like everybody starts with and
then ended up signing a really decent
distribution deal on that so by the time
the movie was already on store shelves
my friends were graduating
so kind of kicked it off that way
and of those friends that graduated how
many actually work in the film industry
now
a lot of them still work in the industry
a lot of them are out here in La
actually and we got to reconnect when we
moved out here and so it's kind of neat
to see where everyone is from that group
some are more successful than others of
course but a lot of them yeah are still
chasing the same dream
and how did they tell you you weren't
accepted as just a form letter yeah I
got a form lever I got a form letter
saying that I wasn't accepted and just
kind of like oh sorry and it was like oh
maybe I shouldn't have submitted with a
short film about a young girl in a
bikini getting chopping people up with
Samurai swords I guess but I thought it
was cool at the time
they didn't give you an answer I mean
sorry they didn't give you a reason why
they didn't no I know that they had
certain quotas to fill as far as other
types of people to be allowed in and so
that I'd heard that reasoning later that
I didn't fit the the certain quota they
needed for certain things but
it all worked out for the best for me
so do you ever Replay that if if you had
been accepted where you think your life
would have taken you
or there may not have been much
difference
I mean I I would bet it'd be very
different because I got into a different
school program that school got me my
first job out of college which was
camera operating in Nickelodeon Studios
on the Backlot at Universal which I made
a bunch of friends there that I'm still
friends with today
and still work with today too so I think
it definitely would have been a totally
different path
a lot of the people in that group moved
out to LA immediately you know started
working trying to work as soon as they
got out here and I stayed in Orlando and
built up a company
um my company Bismol entertainment
celebrates 20 years next year which is
exciting and so I started building up
that multimedia company and getting more
and more clients and starting to do more
and more films and producing for hires
so
yeah I'm pretty happy the way everything
turned out as far as that that one
rejection letter
and do you think that rejection letter
did you a favor and that it made you
want to take risks because you kind of
had this chip on your shoulder or maybe
you didn't but just that you were
willing to try something that you
weren't going to take the safer out
I feel like I'm definitely a risk taker
in situations like that I'm always the
one in the video game that runs into
battle suicidally and
so it I I looked though I started early
I started when I was 16. I got my
passion pretty quickly and knew that I
wanted to go into movie making and so
when I was 16 I grew up in the Florida
Keys on an island so there wasn't nearly
as many opportunities but I went and got
a job with the local cable access
station I started managing a Blockbuster
Video I got an internship with our film
commission so the first films that I
ever got to go on was true lies with
James Cameron so being there on the
seven mile bridge when they land the
Harrier Jets and they're blowing up cars
and stuff and hanging Jamie Lee Curtis
out of a helicopter I was like Wow every
movie is going to be like this which it
is not I'll come to find out later but
I think the one thing about the
rejection letter was it kind of gave you
a place where you had to make a choice
it's like okay
what am I going to do now to get over
this because these people said that
you're not good enough to be this in
this program but I still felt pretty
confident and so my goal was I knew that
I needed to make a feature I knew that
feature films were where all the real
money was and and you can get into video
stores and do all these different things
so that first year I made six short
films in a row because I was like if I
make six short films
all a feature is is one really long
short so if I can make six shorts in a
row then I'll probably teach myself
enough to be able to go and make a full
movie and so that's what I did and just
using friends and everything you know
went and went and just went and did it
and then I started getting a reputation
for myself in town because they're like
well how did this 23 year old idiot get
a movie in Best Buy
and all the older people that were all
upset because they're like well we've
been trying to you know this for years
and I was like oh I don't know I just
went to the video store and saw who was
selling movies and I called them and
said hey I have a movie
do you want to sell it and they said yes
and then you're in Best Buy and people
are so confused but it seemed to me just
at the time common common sense
you figure out how that pathway works
and then once you get the machine
working then it all works out
can you expand on that a little bit more
was it really that simple as finding
who's well who's the distributor on this
film finding their number calling them I
mean to me because I I manage video
stores since I was 16. so I kind of
understood how the video store process
worked I knew that you would have
different chains between Studios to
Distributors to Home Video markets so I
kind of understood that whole process at
the beginning and then when DVDs came
out in the late 90s that totally changed
the Home Video Market and those were so
much cheaper because the time a VHS tape
cost eighty dollars a piece and a DVD
comes out and it costs twenty dollars so
you're already like oh well this digital
format is completely changing the way
the market works because Blockbuster
could buy five times as many DVDs as one
movie so that's when they started doing
the guaranteed to be here and everything
switched over to DVD
so then when I was in college looking at
home video I was like all right well I
understand how this works
and I knew I wanted to make a low budget
horror movie so I literally went to
Hollywood Video and looked at all the
boxes of low budget horror movies that
came out every week or every other week
and saw what company is on the back of
this box and it wasn't Universal it
wasn't Sony you know it was very small
companies brain damage films and and
whatnot and so you would look that
company up because I'm like all right
well this company is the one that sold
to this video store
they're getting movies out there and I
just happen to luck out with the very
first company I called said yes and you
know we ended up getting some money from
it and it paid off the movie it wasn't a
lot of money but we didn't spend a lot
of money at the time so it all kind of
worked out that way
um nowadays it's gotten obviously that
harder well it's just as easy it's just
harder to make money
because you can get your movie out
wherever you want nowadays or you can
put it on YouTube and get 100 million
views if you want you if you technically
could but
back then you didn't have YouTube this
was back in 2003 2002 2003 and so video
stores were still prominent The
prominent way to get movies but the
digital Revolution was happening and so
it was easier to get your you know three
thousand dollar horror movie on the DVD
on a Shelf at the time whereas nowadays
that probably isn't going to happen
when did you leave Blockbuster
uh well I went to college
I was at Blockbuster for three years in
the keys and then when I went to college
in Orlando I worked for another video
store called the video Superstore and I
was there for two years I think
and then that store ended up going under
like during the whole downfall of video
stores you know the eventually when
Netflix came out back then it was a
service where you mailed in they mailed
you a DVD in the mail
uh when that started happening and
people didn't even have to leave their
house anymore then video stores started
going away and Blockbuster couldn't keep
up because they didn't believe in that
at the time and and Mom and Pop video
stores like they were just you know they
couldn't keep up with it either so so at
that time the whole video Market kind of
fell out
um
and that's yes that's why I got out of
that that business